[Music]
greetings of peace welcome to the dean
show very exciting topic as always every
week we're here
sharing the message with you subscribe
to the dean show if you haven't already
now i have a good friend carlos he's a
professor in brazilian jiu jitsu black
belt world champion he was telling me
this wonderful story he brought his
muslim friends down to brazil and these
were his students and now they were
looking for some halal meat what is
halal meat we'll get into that in a
moment so now they went to a farm they
got some chickens i don't know if they
got some ghosts whatever the case but
the natives there they were like what
are you going to do now because they
didn't find the shop so they said look
we're going to take care of the business
ourselves a lot of the animal so the
people where i think they were bringing
out hammers they're like what are these
people going to do how they're going to
do it but once he witnessed how
they slaughtered the animals the people
were like what are these people doing it
was so so easy the
the animals were so relaxed and at the
end he's been a halal meat advocate now
since that happened and
that is the opening now for this week's
show we're going to be talking about
what is this halal meat what do these
muslims do in that country that had
everybody around them fascinated
fascinated with how they prepared the
animals to eat for
human consumption so we're going to be
talking about this
topic that at times people they don't
know they hear about me and they just
panic and there's some controversy
surrounding it at times pizza express is
serving only halal chicken without
telling customers i wouldn't knowingly
buy a halal turkey would you
actually i would in fact most americans
who eat turkey would probably be more
likely to buy a halal or kosher one if
they knew what it stood for but i
guarantee you after this show you even
if you're not a muslim yet you're going
to be a strong advocate of halal meat
and you're probably going to start
eating it too we'll be right back with
our next guest dr muhammad khan here on
the dean show don't go anywhere
this is the theme show
[Music]
thank you very much you're a medical
doctor by profession yes but you're also
excited about sharing this message with
the world that is true now we're going
to be talking about halal meat and
simply halal just permissible isn't it
yes now look i started off with a story
let me just elaborate a little bit on
this story and then we'll take it from
there so what i talked about and more of
the details are that this friend of mine
carlos is a world champion in brazilian
jiu jitsu this is what i trained and he
brought his muslim students down to
brazil with him and they were looking
for some halal me couldn't find a place
obviously in that
neck of the world so they end up getting
some chickens or some animals goats
whatever the case so they did the
slaughtering themselves the natives were
like so amazed at the process they've
never seen something like that they
thought they were working some wudu some
magic or some so ever since then he has
been a strong proponent of eating halal
meat now this friend of mine carlos tell
us what was so unique about this now we
we experience this you know a lot we're
used to it but for someone else when
they see the animal submissive right now
some people are actually seeing there's
a video called mercy slaughter they're
seeing some of this footage how the
animal submits can you walk us through
this a little bit
well that is true that uh halal meat is
certainly a blessing of god the way we
sacrifice the animal it's also very
humane for the animal and it's medically
very beneficial for the human being
who is the consumer and sure enough the
way
your professor friend was telling you
that is the way the animals are
slaughtered i have seen it myself in a
spanish country where the big bulls were
put in in one area where they were
pushed to funnel out in the end there
was only one coming in and the man is
standing on the top of him like about
few feet and he has a long spear kind of
a thing which is hitting the animals
back
constantly and not once because a huge
big bull you know so like about
30 times 40 times and the animal is
bleeding and going through pain and all
the hormones toxic hormones are
increasing in his body
and all the blood is
saturating the meat and then the animal
dies so alhamdulillah when you see that
kind of thing you should we all thank
allah for the way that his prophet told
us how to sacrifice the animal and not
only this
that
that is one area but also the halal meat
has got many benefits for example number
one way people will ask well how will
you find out in the market if it's a
halal meet or not
the one way to find out is that you
could
have two thousand pound or thousand or a
pound you make pieces over there on one
table and in the end you will not even
see one drop of blood there is no drop
of blood in the halal meat so that's
that that's one of the the one of the
the things about halal meat let's back
it up now what are we starting because
isn't this the original way of the jews
and the christians now from way back
that now you start with the name of god
you don't have the permission to take
even this this animal's life
this mercy of islam that now you
pronounce the name of god over it and
you get the permission by the name of
god you slaughter this animal that is
very true we we do that with the name of
god and there's a barakah in it but i
was also trying to highlight to our
non-muslim or not yet muslim brothers
and sisters in america
that there are other medical benefits
too and once they start using this halal
meat they will always use it for example
as i mentioned there's no blood in it
why this is important
that the blood has saturated in all kind
of hormones and
toxins and viruses and other things and
the blood is if it is drained out
you will be
saved from these the toxic effects of
the blood uh the other thing also is
that if you remember you go to the
doctor
he checks and you want him to check your
cholesterol he checks your blood he
doesn't check your urine because it's in
the blood yeah you know so therefore the
people who are high in cholesterol or
high in triglycerides they should
especially eat only halal meat because
it is free from blood so it has got
lesser amount of cholesterol and
triglycerides in it
and also the other thing is that the
meat is fresh
you take one pound of halal meat one
pound of the other put it in there
in one place and later on you're going
to see that the one which is halal is
not going to smell as bad as the other
one and third thing is that it tastes
better now i never ate it the the one
with the blood meat which means
non-halal but the people who have eaten
christians hindus and others they have
always told me that the halal meat once
they started eating it because of taste
they always continued eating it
translate this word again i've said it
but people hear halal now what are we
saying halal means what just halal means
it is clean it is done in the name of
allah it is pure pure from blood there
is no blood in it and also it is very
humane for the animal also because we
all remember in the school age when the
kids are and i as a pediatrician know it
that the mother brings a child saying
that the child fainted out in the school
why i asked him a question he didn't eat
a breakfast so which means what he has a
less sugar and check his blood pressure
which is less blood pressure and what
happens is that there's a less amount of
glucose going to the brain less amount
of oxygen and the child fails same thing
as the animal when you slaughter the
animal you cut its jugular vein keeping
the spine intact and all the blood comes
out the brain sends the commands give me
more blood give me more blood give me
and the body twitches and twitches and
the blood instead of going to the brain
going out going out going and suddenly
fall the level of glucose and the oxygen
and the animal goes in fainting deep
fainting and anesthesia and dies in that
without having any pain beautiful so
while you see other animals they suffer
a lot and all kind of toxins are loaded
in their blood it's more humane
it's
something that is
better for you health-wise and we'll be
talking about more about permissible
meat that's it it's permissible by the
one who created that animal and given it
to you to eat we'll be right back with
more with dr muhammad khan here on the d
show i think of one god he is the cree
he's the only creator of all creations
and he is the one that worthy of being
worshiped and thanked by all his
creations
and he also created lambs and goats as a
blessing for humans
for the purpose of food and clothing
the scriptures also preaches about
humane trait treatment of animals and as
a humans we only have the right to
slaughter them in god's name to be
mentioned before slaughter please
subscribe to the d show follow us on our
official facebook and twitter pages in
the links below please also help support
the d show by making a donation in the
link below
[Music]
back here on the dean's show and we're
talking about permissible meat
permissible by who but the one who
created the meat the creator that's what
halal is it's things that are
permissible things that the creator has
given us now so we take this
this uh animal that now we're kind to
there's mercy towards this animal and
that's what we were seeing in the story
that i opened with that you gave an uh a
great example of people basically
butchering the animal even before it's
before it dies with hammers and whatnot
so when they saw this animal now when
the throat was um slit for the animal in
in a humane way he didn't does the
animal experience any pain he does not
because he certainly goes in fainting
but if you're stunning the animal or
beating the animal statistic they've
done studies on it that now you're
actually traumatizing go into this
definitely when you're stunning the
animal
after the effect of the uh the stunning
he might be stunned but then still he
has
loaded with the blood in him yeah and in
process of that the blood has all the
toxins and viruses as i mentioned to you
and uh saturating the meat and that's
that's what goes into people's stomachs
so uh
in in in halal meat the animal is pure
of blood you know it's gone gone out and
also the cruel method as you mentioned
increases the adrenaline level
in the animal and uh is loaded with
adrenaline and other hormones and which
even makes it worse
there's a hadith also that comes to mind
where the last and final messenger sent
to mankind who's the brother of jesus
moses abraham because we all know they
brought the same message where's the
creator not the creation he was the seal
of the prophets prophet muhammad he said
when you do uh everything we do it in
excellence even now when slaughtering
the animal he taught us the procedure of
doing this in such a humane way
not even the hadith talks about not
killing the animal twice that not even
showing the animal the knife yes right
can you can you talk about this yes the
animal has to be number one there are
certain uh
few points important points that the
animals should be fed well
you should have you should not be empty
stomach not be thirsty not be hungry for
so many days he should be let loose free
and then when he's slaughtered he should
be slaughtered with a sharp knife so it
doesn't feel in pain
it is very fast and secondly it should
not be in front of the other animals who
are standing right there unfortunately
we don't see these kind of things these
days
but in all the muslims wherever they can
do it they all of them try to do this
thing and this is very similar a lot of
people have gotten used to when you say
kosher meat people don't have a problem
with that but why do people have a
problem when you say halal meat how are
halal chicken slaws halal chicken must
be alive when they're slaughtered
of course
everything's gotta be alive before it
dies that is the nature of life
british chickens we always make sure
they're dead before we kill them we
don't even think about killing it it's
been dead like it dies and then we kill
it
some people now some of the people who
um the haters of islam as soon as you
say there's no probable with kosher me
but now when you say halau people get
freaked out why is that well
unfortunately halal
is part of the baggage of the muslims
and they don't like
without even knowing this is the sad
part without even understanding what
islam is what muslims are they just have
a frame of mind a mindset that anything
which is related to muslims or islam is
bad but sure enough kosher and halal
have similarities that both of them are
blood free on both of them name of god
has been taken
and both of them are
prepared in a clean way and sharp knife
and also the difference is important
thing is that price wise
the meat of halal is much cheaper than
the meat of course
we're going to go to this clip right now
no panic hormones whatsoever
aren't you okay baby it's okay i'm not
doing anything good
it's okay baby
same reaction they all react the same
the power of the
word the power of the word gets clearer
and clearer after you see
more and more submit
now in the video you see the animals
they're just like submitting they're not
panicking as he said there's no panic
hormones they're just relaxed what's
going on here well they are relaxed
because to be honest with you i mean the
word of god has been recited on it a few
times as allah says in quran that the
animals are made for human consumption
some of the animals and these animals
are programmed for that
and
therefore when it's done with the name
of allah they become
quiet and peaceful
and plus during the process
with the blood draining out they
suddenly become faint in a little while
but even before that
it's because of the name of the
allah now when you said allah in aramaic
jesus would have said this is a sister
length
is the same god that
jews and christians who are arabic
speaking in the arabic bible they use
the word allah this is not some moon god
or something
that's the same god this is the same god
now this goes back into now let's go off
a little bit here what got you excited
because you're also in the field of
sharing
because we care so we share this message
and the importance because now you're
very active you've actually uh taken out
many ads and many magazines trying to
you know reach out to our brothers in
humanity so that's what i want to focus
on next the importance of educating
people because look just by explaining
what halal
is meaning it's permissible by god
people see the benefits of it hopefully
and they'll probably start eating it
yes but something more important islam
muslims what is this message about some
people attributed to terrorism and
whatnot this is a false notion why is it
so important to do some of the things
that you're also doing but
if every muslim was out there sharing
we wouldn't have most of these problems
that we have
you said it very right brother that we
should be sharing the message of allah
to the other brothers and sisters
this is our responsibility we cannot run
away from it we try to run away but
still this is our responsibility tawa
which is arabic word for reach out is
our responsibility and we should do that
in whichever way we can do it and
certainly i have done in different ways
for example one of the way i've been
doing it as we just mentioned putting ad
in different newspapers and magazines
which are of national level like one of
the magazines
is uh for a psychology
psychologist called counseling today in
the end you will see the ad and this is
this goes to every um
counselor who does counseling with
depression in schools and even the
hospitals are psychiatric and that paper
harvard crimson is of the harvard
university and there's a head in there
four line five line ad this uh india
abroad is for the indian community east
to west coast and then there's another
buddhist community newspaper also which
also goes with the ad in there i put on
five line ads first of that is
questions about islam then second is
peacetv.tv then the third line is about
why islam dot org if you are in the
state which is east of chicago which
means towards new jersey because this
organization is there
if you're on the west of chicago you can
put on gained peace.com the good thing
with gain pieces it has a link with the
show also which is certainly doing a lot
of work and you
alhamdulillah may allah reward you for
that and third is twf.org who is also
trying to correct the misconception
uh on this on the muslims the other ones
are for islam and this one is for muslim
we're going to take a break they're
telling us i'm so sorry to interrupt you
we got to take a break but when we come
back you're going to with your 40 years
plus experience living in this country
now american citizen you're going to be
telling us what the biggest problem
muslims are facing now and how to
correct that is that right yes okay
we'll be right back with dr muhammad
khan here in the dean show probably some
of you are wondering by now about the
arabic words that i use that makes the
animals submit the way they did
the first uh
term we use and this is really uh the
authentic uh procedure one of the terms
of authentic procedure that is being
mentioned in the scripture
is in the name of god the greatest which
is bismillah
there's another prayer that i usually
use and it's my favorite prayer and my
animals favorite prayer the beauty of
this prayer really shows some of the
power of the word itself it says in the
name of god
who is with his name no harm will come
not neither in this earth nor in the
skies and he is the one that hears and
listens and he is the most knowledgeable
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below please also
help support the d show by making a
donation in the link below
[Music]
back here on the dean show now i'm very
you know passionate about sharing
because i care about humanity and i know
that once they experience this
they'll be a totally new persona they'll
be a totally new perception
and it will erase the misconceptions you
know and the bad persona that many
people have and i get excited when other
people see the value of this and you're
one of those people
that is really also excited about
inviting people sharing because it's not
our job to convert anybody it's just to
share right that's right that's right so
you're doing that so before i left uh
we're gonna get after a few more
questions the blueprint
okay you have a great blueprint and
you're gonna share this with our viewers
but what do you see the biggest problem
facing muslims today what is that
problem the biggest problem facing
muslim today in usa is the image problem
unfortunately due to the generations of
hatred that is going on misinformation
and disinformation has become
to the level where people don't even
question it but we as americans we as
muslims it is our duty and
responsibility to bring them the other
side of the story which unfortunately
media does not want to bring it for its
own reasons so we should do that and
each one is responsible for it in this
life in when you look at your
grandchildren you don't if you want them
to be lost
as as muslims have been lost in this
country before they came in 1900 1920s
now you don't find them
but if you want the muslims to remain
and the mosque to remain open now that
you see the churches are closing the
synagogues are closing because they
cannot pay the bills
so the only way we can keep ourselves
our role as american citizens as muslims
is to present islam to the people who
are
not don't know anything about islam or
know only negative things about islam
and the different things which can be
done is one of them is as i mentioned
that we put ads in different newspapers
you can do it too the easiest way to
start the ad is look in your local
newspaper there's a religious directory
which comes in thursday or friday it has
different churches in there places of
worship you call them the rate over
there is the cheapest so it's four times
a month you put an ad over there uh
questions about islam
underneath that you can put on
peacetv.tv
the deenshow.com gamepiece.com
or
the other one is yslam.org
this is important and the other thing
you can do is if you more people join in
and
the money becomes a little more then you
can go on a bigger level
like i have done it but you do in your
own state
and focus in yours so that you saturate
in your state first and the other thing
you can do that that uh like these are
the small booklets that we have uh
why is uh madhuri's uh
towards understanding islam brief
illustrated guide of understanding islam
and professor gerald dirks who is a
former methodist minister has come on
this program his book
uh these books are two dollars to five
dollars
we should try to reach to opinion
molders this is very important opinion
molders are who clergies
libraries
teachers journalists politicians even
mayors we buy these books for example in
bulk and you make a small address of
your own if you don't
you speak with a must mask and force
them pressure them that they should
start a dawa section and then they can
put on that address if that is not ready
yet you can make some small organization
for example if you're in vermont you can
say vermont muslim reaching out post
office box address
and then mail it to the people with the
covering letter and in the end you
please put down on the last page you put
down a a label which should be three
inch five inches with all the five
things uh websites that i mentioned
question about islam why because dawa
it has to be done
in bulk it's like an advertisement tawa
has to be done in bulk and continuous
continuously only then it's going to
work if
if you do it for a little time then
forget about it then it's gone
so we have to be constant about it
this was one of the the first books when
i knew nothing about islam
one of the
and i start to investigate look into
islam you know
this is one of the books now even coming
from a background family muslim but
nobody was practicing you know nobody
really knew the basic tenets of islam
but this when i read this book this book
was so powerful because it gave we want
evidence yes
facts not fiction we don't want some
fairy tales
okay but islam gives us all those facts
so we can know that it's indeed from the
creator who created creation and this
this book was very powerful so i really
recommend anyone who wants to know about
islam get this book
get these books and it loads goes over
everything a very simplistic easy to
read format with some great pictures so
let's recap now so someone doesn't speak
good english doesn't have good
communication skills they can go but
they got some some money now they want
to contribute to doing something good
education is key because once people get
educated they're going to see that islam
doesn't call people to terrorism islam
calls people to be friendly and kind and
the best of manners the best of
character
and
you put the information of how people
can get to a muslim and in these ads
right so people can go now
and contact uh
do you have phone numbers now people
contact you like because you already
know you've made the contacts a lot of
these magazines how could people uh do
you have a list
of that people can contact you so you
can make it easy so then people can say
okay uh contact this newspaper this
newspaper and put an ad and that do you
have something like that set up yeah
they they can contact me if they want to
my email address is m j k h a n
1 1 3 7 3 yahoo.com
and i will discuss with them and explain
them how to do that
but sure enough it's very important that
the people who do these things should be
in contact with the organizations that
we mentioned earlier so that there's no
duplication of resources no waste at one
time because if two people are putting
same ad in newspaper all these papers
can never go into it i see what you're
saying yes so we forgot to mention so
contact some of the organizations that
they can gain peace or why islam yes
someone get with that keep them informed
when you put an ad so that somebody else
wants to put an ad in the same newspaper
not knowing that you are doing it in the
same town then these people can tell you
no
somebody else is doing it you do in some
other newspaper eventually if you work
together like this inshallah we can
reach out to as many of our american
brother and sister rural area which is
very important unfortunately that is
being neglected by most of the
organizations in this country muslim
organizations because they're based in
the big cities but the america is 80
percent rural we have to reach out to
them in the villages and less popular
states and cities we're out of time
unfortunately
thank you so much i'm very excited to
have you on the program thank you
continue with your perseverance continue
sharing the truth inshallah allah grant
you jannah thank you
and you got to learn about halal me
permissible me the animal must not be
diseased if the turkey has tumors or
cysts it's not certified the meat must
not come in contact with contaminants
you know like worms bugs dirt feces
bacteria things that are also not
allowed by federal meat inspectors all
the blood must be allowed to drain out
before packaging by the one who created
the meat the one who created the animal
and out of his mercy now he's made it
submissive for you when you pronounce
god's name over it and you do do it the
right way you got health benefits as the
doctor went over
by draining all the blood out in the
procedure and you see that very similar
to kosher
that's it it's it's it's the right
process so you can have the most
beneficial outcome
and it's the way that jesus slaughtered
the meat
moses abraham but they did something
even greater than that they only
worshiped the one who created that meat
who created that animal the one god
and that is what islam is based on and
now as the last and final messenger
prophet problem peace be upon him
whoever invites to something good will
have the reward equivalent to the one
who does it so
the invitation is very important in
education so we also covered a way and
the doctor muhammad he gave us a little
bit of a blueprint that you can go ahead
and contribute and do your part it's
very important that everyone shares
otherwise do you really care because
again if you care you share
so
what's holding you back from getting out
there and educating the people and he's
given you a way to do that so inshallah
god willing we can be successful and we
get that reward and
we get the agenda so continue to tune in
to the dean's show subscribe if you
haven't already follow us on facebook
twitter and we'll see you next time here
on the dean show until then peace be
with you please subscribe to the d show
follow us on our official facebook and
twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the d show by making a
donation in the link below